c'est un projet titanesque qui se
dessine dans la baie de saint brieuc en
bretagne un parc de 60 deux éoliennes
émergent à seulement 16 kilomètres de la
côte un chantier qui inquiète les
pêcheurs soucieux du renouvellement des
réserves de poissons dans cette région
on est sur une des zones
les plus importantes peut-être en termes
d'activité de pêche liées notamment à la
fonctionnalité de la baie de saint
brieuc c'est une zone importante pour le
développement la reproduction la pompe
de nombreuses espèces les marins
pêcheurs a été très clair depuis le
début c'est à dire d'avoir des réponses
sur les impacts aujourd'hui on n'y est
pas on n'a pas assez réponse des
craintes pour la pérennité des espèces
sauvages partagé par l'association gok
le groupe d'étude des oiseaux de côtes
d'armor certaines espèces certaines
populations d'oiseaux peuvent à terme
éviter cette zone d'implantation et plus
globalement la baie de saint brieuc donc
éviter cette zone là c'est perdre une
partie de leur habitat et quand on sait
que ce sont les populations finalement
assez réduite
ça peut devenir inquiétant alors pour se
faire entendre le comité des pêches des
côtes d'armor a déposé le 24 septembre
dernier deux recours pour suspendre et
annuler ce projet devant le tribunal
administratif de rennes
au nom du principe de l'urgence
environnementale
problème la bretagne importe 80% de
l'énergie électrique qu'elle consomme ce
parc éolien pourrait produire
l'équivalent de la consommation annuelle
de 8 135 mille habitants un projet dont
la région peut difficilement se passer
il faut que chacun ait conscience qu'il
y a un enjeu c'est de produire de
l'électricité
il faut décarbonés l'économie c'est
indispensable si on ne veut pas de
nuisance sur terre si on ne veut pas de
nuisances en mer mais qu'on veut quand
même de l'énergie à un moment donné ça
va poser quelques problèmes la décision
du tribunal administratif de rennes est
attendue cette semaine quelle qu'elle
soit les travaux en mer seront suspendus
en novembre pour la période hivernale en
raison de la météo quelques mois
peut-être pour trouver une entente sur
le dossier de l'éolien breton